women no longer exist as characters in
the movies you cannot go to the movies
and see a woman who is anything like a
woman that you would actually meet
unless you date wrestlers you know what
I mean you know and when my daughter was
growing up there would be a scene and a
woman would punch a guy and the guy
would roll ass over teeth and I would
say to her you know if you punch a guy
the first thing that happens is your pan
breaks and the second thing that happens
is he beats the living crap out of you
you know and so don't don't ever think
that that's the real thing so feminism
destroyed
the character of the woman and yet
that's what stories are about they're
about whether a woman can be
um womanly enough and whether a man can
be manly enough to keep life going is
the West coming to an end something is
coming to an end and when when things
come to an end it's a very dangerous
moment and I think that there are
probably a hundred good years left to
the republic or 100 years left to the
public they may not be that good
and then and then I think something else
will come
thank you
hey Constantin do you like romantic
novels no in my countrymen who read
romantic novels are executed which is
correct this is why we don't have men
with pink hair or women with unshaved
armpits oh I might chill out how about
if the character was woke even worse
Lennon would have been spinning his
glass case but what if it's satirical in
my country would do not have satar
laughing is not allowed if you want
humor red dostoyevski well if you were
blessed with a sense of humor and enjoy
a bitingly funny takedown of romance
novels and World culture then you have
to read Danielle's passion a new set
hour that follows a young ivy league
grad as she battles white supremacy the
patriarchy and late stage capitalism in
the hellscape that is Irvine California
this is not natural live laugh and love
to the eyes of one of your most
superiors suffer every microaggression
judge every co-worker betray every
family member as if you were doing it
yourself and come out feeling just as
smug this sounds like almost Russia now
I'm interested in this book it's comedy
done the right way no lectures no
messages no characters banging on about
the same Tire talking points satire as
it's meant to be solved if you want
great we'll go to Amazon and click on
link below we also recommend you buy
Tide moderates other books won't
fragility and a little book of woke
jokes click on Luke and laugh like
you're reading Warren please
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
yesterday is an author and former
Hollywood screenwriter Andrew cleven
welcome to trigonometry it's great to
see you guys uh listen man it's it's an
absolute pleasure to have you on the
show there's so many things we're going
to talk about that I can't can't wait
but for anyone who is not familiar with
your story it's a very interesting one
it's a it's a very interesting Journey
you've had in terms of your religion and
Views and all sorts of things so who are
you how are you where you are what's
been your journey through life well I'm
right I've been a writer all my life
it's all I ever wanted to be I was a
mystery writer I kind of fell in love
with the American tough guy writers when
I was a kid and so I made my way as a
mystery writer and did very well you
know won awards and had movies made and
and then as you say I kind of thought
before I age out which is I think about
the age of 22 I wanted to try Hollywood
so I went to Hollywood and I did that
for a while and uh that was working well
except that I uh you were hugely
successful done on the players what's
that you were hugely I was doing I was
doing quite well yeah in Hollywood I
mean in Hollywood you can do well
without any movies getting made you just
sell the script you're making a bundle
and it was uh uh but I was having fun
but unfortunately I had been living in
the UK for uh seven years all through
the 90s and I came back and shortly
after I came back 9 11 happened
and I had come back from the UK without
realizing it I had become politically
conservative and I didn't even know it
because I wasn't dealing with American
politics I was dealing only with British
politics and you know I didn't really
care I just was paying attention to them
and I came back and I suddenly found
that all of the people that I liked
listening to from Rush Limbaugh on uh
were conservatives and I thought well
that's a shock because I had left I had
been a Jewish liberal you know typical
Jewish Coastal liberal
um and at the same time or really
slightly afterwards a long long journey
of conversion Came Upon me and so when I
say I was Jewish I was racially Jewish
but I had no religion and I suddenly
began to realize I was a Christian and
so at the same time I became a loudmouth
conservative because 9 11 had happened
in Hollywood was making these movies
showing us as the bad guys and they were
making movie after movie showing us as
the bad guys and I thought this is a
terrible thing to do even the movies
that were opposed to Vietnam were made
after Vietnam was over and so I started
to talk about that and write about that
and I even went to Afghanistan and had
myself embedded with the troops I could
speak with authority and I said you guys
are really messing this this is wrong
it's wrong when when their guy it's not
wrong to disagree with the war but while
our guys are being shot at you shouldn't
be making movies like this
well that on top of becoming a Christian
my Hollywood career died like that I
mean it was instantaneous but
simultaneously because God does take
care of his poets and his fools uh and
on both I started to do these kind of
satirical videos about conservatism and
that became a second career and so now I
I have this kind of remarkable career
it's like this is now uh as I enter what
must be the last phase of my life unless
I'm Immortal
um you know I find myself having the
career of my of my dreams I'm writing uh
non-fiction about the things I
understand in the culture and how
Christianity speaks through them I'm
still I have a new mystery Series going
on and I'm working at the daily wire as
a podcaster
um and it's it's really been a
remarkable Journey the only thing I'm
not doing anymore is Hollywood and to be
honest with you I never really liked the
movie business anyway I mean it's just
it was just something I did because it
seemed like the next step in my career
right so that's the one thing that has
been I was literally canceled I mean I
was literally just blacklisted and went
dark there but other than that things
have been remarkable yeah uh and one of
the things you said to me because we met
here last year
and I still remember this we were
talking about screenwriting and and
writing in general and you said every
great Story begins with a boy and a girl
and once I got past the transphobia and
the homophobia of that statement
it really made me think because that is
so fundamentally true
and yet I think we've become quite
uncomfortable with telling a story as
basic as that or a story that is based
on such a simple thing well women no
longer exist as characters in the movies
you cannot go to the movies and see a
woman who is anything like a woman that
you would actually meet unless you date
uh wrestlers you know what I mean you
know
probably I mean if when you talk about
you know before the cameras are rolling
we're talking about all the
controversial things we say and how
people get angry yeah maybe the thing
that made people angrier than anything
else I've ever said on the air was I I
saw a show The Witcher in which the
woman was fighting a duel
and I said
women can't fight duels with men that's
not the way that works I mean if it's
the Middle Ages and you're in an actual
battle not on a fencing field
those guys were like you know it's not
like you'd be fighting me you'd be
fighting a guy this gigantic guy and
he'd come and just wipe you off the face
of the Earth if you have a character and
a fantasy who's a woman she should have
some magical power because women do have
that but but you can't keep putting
women in who fight because that doesn't
happen in real life and and when my
daughter was growing up there would be a
scene and a woman would punch a guy and
the guy would roll ass over teeth and I
would say to her you know if you punch a
guy the first thing that happens is your
pan breaks and the second thing that
happens is he beats the living crap out
of you you know and so don't don't ever
think that that's the real thing so
feminism destroyed
the character of the woman and yet
that's what stories are about they're
about whether a woman can be
um womanly enough and whether a man can
be manly enough to keep life going to
keep the planet you know the human race
uh continuing
um and and in telling that story you
were telling an essential uh what's
called a psychomochy the the inner
battle that we all fight to bring
together the pieces of ourselves because
we all have female and male elements and
we when you put those together uh you
are getting something like the image of
God you know in which we are made and so
that story is is the story and once you
lose that story you're not telling any
story at all and it really is
interesting I mean I went just the other
day my wife and I went and saw the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie and the first
thing that happens is a giant bad guy
comes in tip is a classic scene because
this is the scene where Brad Pitt is
reading the script and says oh yeah I
want to play that part bad guy comes in
he's a monster he's huge comes up to a
woman the woman just beats the crap out
of him and I thought yeah you've already
lost me you know the rest and and in
fact the film is entertaining it's
beautiful but it's dead inside it has no
inside because that character that
female character women no longer know
who they're supposed to be and they get
insulted if you say to them well you may
be many things but the one thing you're
not is a man you know and so you have to
understand what you are as a woman and
that that has been outlawed as a as an
idea and signify something in the
culture to me that that very basic it's
the core it's like a house without a
foundation
well you know I I wrote this book The
the truth and beauty and I have a
chapter on Frankenstein by Mary shellin
and I point out that when people read
Frankenstein it's it really starts the
science fiction genre she basically
invents the modern uh science fiction
when people read that they always say
well Frankenstein wanted to be God he
wanted to create life and Mary Shelley
herself said this and I thought no men
do create life men and women do create
life he wants to replace not God he
wants to replace the mother he wants to
create a life without a woman and and
that is to a large degree with science
fiction is about and to a large and even
larger and worst degree with science is
about it has been a long uh attempt to
eliminate the fertility
and the difference of women because men
are afraid of that power and that's what
Mary Shelley I thought first saw that
you know if you think of think of a
movie like The Terminator you know the
machines take over and they and the
people rebel so how do they stop the
Rebellion they go back in time to kill
the hero's mother
and if you see watch that first
brilliant film
the woman they want to kill
she has nothing special about her except
she she's a girl that's her superpower
you know and they know they've got to
kill her because that's the Machine
World depends on women being taken away
this is you know just right this moment
people were yelling at me on Twitter
because I said we should uh boycott
Anheuser-Busch for putting a boy
pretending to be a girl on one of their
beer cans they said oh this is such a
small thing why are you getting so upset
this is everything this is everything
the role of women in a society who after
all create humankind
um is is everything and that's why
societies that have Freer women who
liberate women who have respect for
women that's why they Thrive and
societies that don't get stuck in a kind
of medieval half-life
and it's important because soon there'll
be machines that give birth
and then we'll turn to women and say and
what do you what's special about you I
can run faster than you I'm stronger
than you are I can do math better than
you can do it what is it you do again
and they'll have lost their vocation
it's a dangerous dangerous moment and
because our Humanity depends on them
it's such a profound point and that's
that is really what we're seeing and
we're seeing it right the way through
our culture
when are we going to wake up from this
Andrew well hopefully you know we're not
going to wake up until women get angry
and and this is the thing you know uh my
friend and colleague at the daily wire
Candace Owens was just saying when they
did it to Budweiser beer
suddenly Budweiser beer took an economic
hit and she said why because Men drink
Budweiser beer and they get angry but
women not real men not right no of
course of course not and certainly not
men with any taste and beer or anything
but but she was just saying that men
don't take this stuff quite as much as
women do women have been convinced
my problem with feminism was always the
same thing it was always it was not that
women shouldn't have choices it was that
their values are men's values they say
oh you're just a homemaker
I think really just a homemaker I mean
is I mean isn't the home the basic
building block of the State uh you know
just you're just raising children you're
just creating new people that has been
the feminist uh archetype from the very
beginning uh Simone de beauvois said
women should not be allowed to stay home
and raise their kids because too many
women will choose to do that and they
have been convincing women uh that this
is a minor thing this is being thrown
out of the society So when you say how
long will this last the answer is until
you start to have women saying wait a
minute wait a minute we've been duped
we've been duped out of ourselves and
you're starting to see it now I mean we
were talking about Mary Harrington who's
just This brilliant uh you know Oxford
educated thinker and she you know had a
baby she was totally in with the left
had a baby and she thought no I actually
kind of like this I actually kind of
want to do this and when more thinking
women have that kind of Courage
then you've got you'll have ideas
trickling down that will counter
feminism because feminism has just been
a mistake it has made everybody
miserable
you wonder why yeah
but let's move to the movie business for
a little bit I'm a huge movie fan okay
I've Loved movies right the way from
from Year Dot it's my passion my love
movie buff movie nerd whatever
what's going on with the movies I can't
remember I mean there's the odd movie
that comes along I go oh I'd like to see
that but nothing really compels me like
it used to yeah but what's going on well
there's there's two things one is that
art forms have a natural life cycle uh
you know they can come back they don't
necessarily die forever but they rise up
at their Peak usually very early on to
me the peak year of the movies is 1939 I
mean and what happens at that Peak is
that the popular movies and the
critically acclaimed movies are the same
movie
so when you get it when you get oh I see
where this is going well it's true you
know you've got an era like where the
theater is thriving Shakespeare is the
popular playwright uh you're getting the
novels are thriving Dickens you know one
of the greatest novel novelists ever is
also the best-selling novelist 1939 if
you look at the 10 Oscar nominees
they're also some of the greatest films
ever made including the Wizard of Oz and
you know I don't know if gone with the
win was that year but it's almost that
year
um
Mr Smith one of the Frank Capital
as an art form ages out
they split into uh popular trash like
these Marvel movies these superhero
movies and these kind of tiny little
intellectual exercises that the critics
think are oh so important but the rest
of us can't stay awake through and
that that's the one thing that's
happening it's simply a matter of the
art form aging out and a lot of that
energy went over to TV in the 2000s the
early 2000s I remember watching a show
here called the shield and thinking oh
gee they're doing everything I did in
the golden the second golden age of
mystery writing I was writing characters
just like this and now they've all moved
over to TV and that and we had 20 years
of great TV here I mean it was really
brilliant stuff
but the other thing is this this idea of
of wokeness which is actually uh a very
deep we use it as a slogan
uh as a catch word but it's actually a
very deep
philosophical moment it is the bottom of
atheistic philosophy and it's impossible
to make a good story out of it because
it has no inner life it the whole the
whole premise of wokeness is there is no
spiritual life there's only Power
everything that we believe in is power
femininity is power masculinity the
constructs of power and so they can't
say anything you can't you can't say
anything about what it is to be a human
being you know uh there is we're talking
about there are no women characters I've
always thought what would it what would
happen if you told a story in which a
woman character starts out as a powerful
business woman and then says you know
what I don't want to do this I want to
make a family I want to I want a man to
take care of me so I can do this you
know you can't make that movie and yet
that is the movie right you can't make a
movie where a guy comes to town and
builds a business
and he's the hero of the movie you know
because it's all about power so if he
has power he must be the bad guy when
you get rid of the spiritual life
there's only Power and and that's not a
good story wow you know what you're
investment of uh to I don't know if
you're familiar with him he's a KGB
Defector uh from the Soviet Union uh in
in the like he has lectures on YouTube
and this is uh this is one of the things
he talked about how in the movies at
certain point uh the police the generals
the army they all became the bad guys
the criminal is the good one the the KGB
uh not not the KGB the army colonel he's
always the dumb one the the whatever but
I want to come back to the first of
those two Andrew because
what you're talking about is a perfect
metaphor for politics more broadly
because you you have a an elite
that is so up its own us it is
completely out of touch with ordinary
person and so which is typical by the
way right we're right and so that's why
the movie or that that there's the
screen the screenshots from like the
Rotten Tomatoes ratings for comedy shows
like a Dave Chappelle latest show or a
movie and now their their parodies on
themselves where like critics a hundred
percent you know uh for the for they
like or dislike something and it's the
opposite way for the ordinary person
right and it seems to me like it's not
just about aging out it's about a
fundamental Detachment of the people in
in a in like in this case in Hollywood
from the people who they're supposed to
provide services or content or whatever
it is right but this is how this is how
an art form dies it is it is a
coagulation of power in a way you know
we're sitting a few miles from
Washington in Washington you can go to
Georgetown named after Washington and
walk down the street that used to be
called Washington Street with inside of
the Washington Monument in the middle of
Washington DC so you get the picture
that George Washington a lot of a big
effect on this
um on this country and the thing that is
Washington's signal moment is having
defeated the British in this defeated
the greatest Empire on Earth with his
ragtag band of you know half starlings
uh that's wandering around in the snow
he's got
he's the king of a continent he can be
the king of a continent there was
nothing to stop him and he takes he goes
to uh somewhere in Maryland and
Annapolis and he turns over his sword to
the civilian Powers because he believed
that much in the idea of The Sovereign
people
that also just like you said has aged
out so that at that moment the most
popular man in America was also the best
man in America and probably one of the
best men who ever lived you know he was
like but he was also the most now like
the people who are popular are
completely detached from the the power
and the people who are powerful are
completely detached from the people
um the Advent of Donald Trump which even
at the time I said you know this is a
tragic moment when it takes a man like
Donald Trump to speak for the people
because everybody and you saw the way
the power Just Came to shut him down
this is not about whether Trump's a nice
person or a good person or anything like
that it's simply what he represented to
people for for 50 years
50 years the powers that be told people
in this country you stink your country
stinks your religion stinks your cut the
color of your skin stinks everything
about your history it stinks you know
like your God doesn't exist
and then they thought well why did they
elect Donald Trump
you know my feeling was you're lucky
they didn't show up outside your house
with a torch and a pick Pitchfork and
toss you into the Potomac you know this
was the nice thing electing Donald Trump
was the nice thing to do so you're
absolutely right I mean I think that
um as as people
people think their way out of morality
as as they think their way out of
your individuality the importance of
your individuality it's easy for me to
feel my individuality and my reality but
you have to have to sort of really think
about it to think oh you know maybe that
guy's sitting across from me is just as
important to himself as I am to me and
and that we're both equally important to
God then you have art then you have the
enlightenment then you know once you get
that idea
then you have all the kind of beautiful
things that that Europe produced and
once you lose that idea you lose
everything and and I think you're
absolutely right that kind of
coagulation of of power money uh
political ideas in in an aristocracy
that does not care anymore for the
people that has no no blessed oblige is
the way a country ages out as well
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
are War shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch them after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and you can see it but going back to
this idea of the movies where the values
that America used to embody and use to
celebrate if you think about the movies
of the 80s and 90s strength resilience
Independence taking responsibility for
yourself
you look at the movies now and they just
it's unrecognizable you think to
yourself what message are you trying to
send me how are you trying to inspire me
yes well that's well that is a you know
it's an amazing thing the people who
built the movie industry the people who
made the movies I I love and probably
you love as well many of them were
immigrants many of them were Jews and
they loved this place they loved America
I mean because they'd seen what the rest
of the world was like especially the
Jewish guys they knew exactly what what
they had going on in America and they
were liberal in the sense that they
wanted to be included
but they were businessmen who thought
their business depended on the audience
liking what they did so if the audience
was Christian they give them Christians
they have a scene where the Christian
guy would be nice to a Jew and then and
you know that would give you a good
feeling and they would say yes we're
part of this country too and everybody
said yes you are
that that was great stuff but they loved
they may not have loved the people uh
individually but they loved them as the
audience they were their source of their
income they were the source of their
popularity their power everything and
they served them they served the people
partially because the studio system was
destroyed by the courts
the essentially the inmates took over
the Asylum uh in Hollywood this is part
of the the deaths throws of the industry
but you had this moment when they lost
the studio system Studios had a monopoly
they had a monopoly on theaters the
court said you can't they it was a trust
busting case and they destroyed that
so ultimately now the power rested with
actors and not with businessmen and so
you got you have actors who were great
businessmen like Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Tom Cruise they're great businessmen
but they're still not about the people
those are bad examples because Cruz and
Schwarzenegger actually are about the
people but so many of these guys you
know you make a movie even an Oscar to a
movie like what was it called Moonlight
was that was what it was called it was
when oscar-winning film about a black
gay guy discovering that he's gay you
know it wasn't a bad film but it was
like a slice of Life about this you know
like this and then you think about Gone
With the Wind you think about the movies
that have won Oscars that were just gave
you all of life you know they gave you
so many Casablanca I mean that that
movie you can watch that movie today you
can watch it twice in a row today and
it'll still break your heart whereas you
know a black gay guy in the in the
ghettos is an interesting story I'll
watch that once you know it's not it's
not telling me something that I need to
know to get forward in life whereas the
fact that sometimes you have to give up
the thing you love for a greater cause
is something I needed to know the movies
shaped you know it's funny
the Arts shaped me you know I I wasn't
happy at home I had a bad relationship
with my dad I went to the
first to novels and then to movies for
male role models and I found Bogart John
Wayne these you know Raymond Chandler's
Philip Marlow the great detective guy
Sam Spade
um
and they taught me these simple things
you know they taught me how to walk they
taught me you know how to what you what
you would sacrifice for they taught me
that you would sacrifice for something
during the pandemic recently there was
this moment when Donald Trump got
covered and he came back to the White
House
and he said I've now I've had covet
Don't Be Afraid don't let it dominate
your life
and there is this Montage that I play on
my show from time to time of the news
media coming out going what a horrible
thing to do of course you should be
afraid of course this this could kill
you what's wrong you know that and I I
don't know if I was the last person in
America with all those movies in my head
saying wait a minute you know there are
there are things that are more important
than dying you know like slavery like
being like losing your freedom like
losing your dignity like you know losing
the chance to be the thing that you want
to be people have died for all those
things through time and yet here with
the news that was the news media one of
them after another say no no no that
mean awful Donald Trump you know you
must be afraid you must be afraid and
then they sit around going why would
anybody vote for Donald Trump you know
these are the things we learned from the
movies uh and we learned them before
that from you know British novels I
think more than anything else uh and
these are the things that are gone
in my opinion from a world without God
because why would you why would you risk
your life
if there's nothing Beyond yourself you
know why would you risk your life for
anything if there's nothing Beyond
yourself if something doesn't have a
quality of the Eternal to it uh like
Freedom like uh you know justice of
those things why would you die for them
if uh if everything is just material
you know you're here you're gone and
that's the reason I'm such a huge Arthur
Miller fan the playwright Arthur Miller
and his wife for me the the play The
Crucible resonates harder than ever
especially now yeah when you have
Proctor and he give John Procter at the
end when he's about to he's about to die
and he refuses
to
give give up anybody else and he says
but leave me my name that's all I have
that's all that any man has yes and and
then think you know with Andrew Cuomo
who's made a hero he was the governor of
New York yeah and he was made into a
hero the anti-trump yeah and he said you
know we have to do all this stuff
because it's death and nothing is worse
than death death is death and death when
you're dead you're dead you know you
just look like who are these people like
like run and hide everybody and and you
know this is this is kind of the
instrument of power everything is a
catastrophe everything is an emergency
the climate is an emergency you go like
you know it's it's a little warm today
oh my it's an emergency give me more
power you know racism is an emergency
reason this is a health emergency you
know give us more power uh the covert is
emergency give us more power there's
always back to that you know it's always
basically they're gonna take care of it
let me ask you a question I don't like
asking because I don't like hearing the
answer but
if Hollywood is aged out and comedy is
aged out and and if we're seeing the
same thing in in Western political
systems
is the West coming to an end
well it's a good question uh the West
has come to an end before uh and it came
it came slowly back
um my guess is I don't think so
something is coming to an end and when
when things come to an end it's a very
dangerous moment
um the baby boom generation is dying
um
there's no generation to take their
place I did a Show recently about King
Lear which is about the same situation
the old man is dying there's nobody to
take his place because they haven't
learned the things you need to learn to
take uh to take the next gener the last
Generations plays uh the post-world War
II order is done
a post uh Cold War order is dying a lot
of stuff is coming to an end right now
and in times like that certain things
happen there's gender confusion always
always gender confusion in moments like
this uh there's a the threat of War
because
there's no common ground right now in
America we have no common ground there's
no Common Ground between left and right
plenty of Common Ground among the people
like I would say about 70 percent of the
people probably agree on seventy percent
of the ideas but among the loudest
people uh there's no common ground and
that's a that's could could lead to
actual shooting War
um
however
I think that the foundation on which
America stands and the alliance that it
has built with both what was once great
Europe and some of you know Israel and
the Middle East and Eastern Europe I I
think there's a lot of energy still in
there political energy and Military
energy and possibly Financial energy and
what I if I had to predict something uh
what I would say I'm much more afraid of
losing the American Republic than I am
of losing America
so remember after the Roman Republic
fell
Roman Empire Still lasts another 400
years it lasted as long as it had
already lasted
so I'm I'm
fearful for our Republic because it's
not working it has ceased to work the
way it's supposed to operate
um
but I still feel you know China I don't
think so people keep telling me Oh
China's the future I don't think so I
think it's a stagnant it's all an
already dying Society I don't think you
can have a free market without political
freedom I think they've made a mistake I
think they're going to age out too you
know I I think that I think that the
West still has something in it
and that what we're really seeing now I
mean one of the things that happened in
Rome like if you were in Rome you were
thinking where are all the Romans all
these immigrants are coming in this is
bad Romans but actually that's that's
the sign of an idea spreading all these
people who are shouting at us that
they're not being treated fairly are
shouting British ideas of us you no it's
like you don't go you don't go to like
Africa and say you know we want to be
equal because that doesn't mean anything
in Africa you know it only means
something here because we're all British
that's that's why so what's happening
really is we're bringing in the people
of the world we're anglicizing them
that's our job I think I think that's
just the same way the Roman job was to
spread the ideals of Greece I think the
American job is to spread the ideals of
England I think that's actually
happening and I think that there are
probably a hundred good years left to
the republic or 100 years left to the
public they may not be that good
and then and then I think something else
will come you know but I think it will
still be Western uh for a long time
that's my guess
I say that and we could all blow up as
we're speaking here but that's my that's
my guess you know
I I see when I talk when I talk to
Andrew I I enjoy it so much because when
I went into the art
I expected it to be full of people like
you people questioning people opening
who are open we could debate we could
discuss you disagree you see yourself as
a conservative I remember you when we
were having a conversation you looking
at me and going you're a conservative
you just don't know it yet which is what
I get from everybody when I come here
but
the Arts isn't full of people like you
it isn't full of people who are
interesting and interested and curious
and open to new ideas
why is that what's gone wrong you know
it's a really good observation when I
when I was coming up
I was you know I fell in with some
really talented writers
some of them went on to have really
great careers and the discussions that
we would have were fantastic you know
talking about what is happening to
storytelling where we want us to take
storytelling what storytelling meant to
us within years we had all done fairly
well and we were talking about who's
your agent how'd you get that why did
you get that deal I didn't get that deal
nobody said you know and I thought I
hate these people I'm not talking to
people and and one of the things that
was kind of lovely about becoming a
writing thinking conservative was
suddenly I saw that again when we were
building the daily wire the daily wire
started it was me and Ben Shapiro and
Jeremy boring and soon Michael Knowles
came in and we did nothing but fight
with each other we we fought so much
that sometimes the women I I remember
once I went home and one of the women
called me and said are you in Ben okay
and I said yeah that's how we talked to
one another because we were screaming it
you know but it was totally friendly it
was just we were just absolutely and and
something about success takes that out
of people you know they they want to
hold on to what they've got and they
lose that I've never lost it I mean this
is why I'm here I'm here to talk and
debate and hear things I'm here to be
proved wrong you know I mean I I being
proved wrong doesn't mean anything to me
because it means I've now learned
something new you know I've actually
broken through a wall a cage that I was
in but this is it's it's a remarkable
thing because
one of the drawbacks to this internet
culture is that if you're wrong people
are like you were wrong you know it was
yeah you know that happens to me
sometimes it may happen again
uh but but to me that's that is that's
the glory of of doing what we do uh that
you can that you can grow and you can
change and that the books that you write
uh at 50 or not the books we write at 30
in the books that you write a 70
shouldn't be the books you write at 52
you know you should get deeper and
richer and that means leaving things
behind but you're absolutely right we
are in a culture that has shut that
first we were in a culture I just saw it
as as people got rich they started
stopped doing it that may just be part
of nature you know
um but also we're in a culture that
doesn't allow you to do that like you
know
there's a there's a problem in this
country where I think 50 of the murders
in this country are committed by black
people now to me that's a really big
question why is that now I have a theory
about it my theory is it has to do with
the programs that the left instituted uh
during the 60s 70s and 80s that made
them a dependent class turned blacks
into a dependent class but Charles
Murray is a terrific thinker and he
believes it's genetics and of course
then the left has their theory that it's
all racism and they're you know it's we
we did this to them
um
you can't have that conversation you
know for saying what I even for saying
what I just said I'm a racist oh I
flinched even though I know the
statistics and I've listened to Larry
Elder and Thomas I'll talk about it and
I've looked at the arguments I Flinch
when you say it yeah because that's the
culture we're in I I brought up Charles
Murray at the dinner party in LA and
somebody said isn't he that racist you
know he's he's not a racist at all but
he does believe in genetic more than I
do I'm not like a big and he could be
wrong he could be totally wrong you know
but I I had him on the show I wanted to
hear what he had to say and he made a
you know we had a really interesting
conversation and I I pushed back against
him he was absolutely civilized and you
know pushed back against me it was it
was great stuff uh but we have now shut
that down and that too is contributing
to the uh atrophy of the Arts because
what are the Arts but you know that kind
of open-mindedness I mean they you can't
even write a story you can't even write
a story if you don't have an open mind
because your story has to mean things
that you didn't mean it to me for a
story to come to life you have to let it
set it free you know you can't just say
oh this this has to happen to that
character because I'm a you know I'm a
capitalist and I don't want the
Communist to win you can't write a story
like that you have to let the story tell
itself you know
um and all of that stuff requires a
certain fearlessness that artists are
renowned for but have no longer got
um you know you can
I mean I have I'm writing this new
series of uh mystery stories uh and and
I have a new one the third one is coming
out in October at the end of October and
I handed it in and had a glancing
reference
to transgenderism maybe five lines so
you have to take this out I said I will
pull that book before I take out
anything for political reasons you know
you know one of my the New York Times is
going to give me a bad review I've said
things about the New York Times I think
they may show up in my house one day
like no you know that that's insane it's
insane to have to kowtow to you know a
bunch of
and basically adolescents who've been
taught something in college and don't
know enough to disagree you know I mean
that's it's it's very stultifying and
it's also as you say it's it's
dull you know I want to be with people
who who disagree and are fearlessly
disagree and
um and don't call each other names you
know when when they say something and
Andrew
forgive me for saying this but what
you're describing to me are old school
liberal values yes so this is what I
find mind-boggling I'm 40 years old when
I was a young guy watching comedy and
being inspired by it the people who were
really pushing back against the dogma of
the day were people like George Carlin
and Bill Hicks who whose targets were
religious conservatives right so if you
talk about stultifying they were the
ones you know Bill Hicks last Letterman
appearance was wasn't broadcast for I
think over a decade because he made fun
of religion right so when I came into
adulthood it was conservatives at least
that was the kind of the way it was
presented who were the people who were
refusing to have the conversation right
and it was the liberals who were let's
let's have that robust debate that
you're talking about that was the
lifeblood of my my young adulthood that
was what I loved I cherished that
so what happened how like you you talked
about it in your own life you were this
you know liberal went over to the UK
came back conservative uh and we on
neither of us is conservative but we
find ourselves mostly talking to people
who are in the center or right of center
right because the left does the six
degrees of white supremacy thing where
if you talk to this guy and he sat next
to that guy who's dog blah blah blah
then you can't you know you can't talk
to them anymore
how how how are the three of us sitting
here well because when I said to you
that you know Francis that you're a
conservative I I said this to Mary
Harrington who also tells me she's on
the left but but there is no left there
is no you know in the in the 50s I think
it was a famous literary critic named
Lionel trilling said there is no until
such thing as an intellectual
conservative there are no conservative
ideas they're only conservative gestures
you know it was a very snobby snooty
thing to say but he had a point now
that's true of the left but it's not
true of the right uh on the left there
there are no ideas there are no ideas on
the left I mean you know their their
ideas are like yeah you can print money
because that's fine and you know you
can't arrest black people because
they're brown they have this color skin
and you know you're you're white and
therefore you're evil you know those
aren't ideas those are gestures those
are kind of virtue signaling uh
movements of the of the chin but they're
not like something that you can debate
in any serious way a man can become a
woman you know as if yeah like what are
you even talking about on the right
basically the right now contains those
people like me I mean I always say this
I always say I'm a conservative because
I'm a liberal I'm a conservative because
I want people to be free I want other
people to be able to have the life that
they want to have not the life I want
them to have I know how everybody should
live you know I could explain to you but
but it's none of my business you know
you know that that actually is my
religion that's actually in the gospels
you know leave people alone don't judge
people you know let them do what they're
going to do let them work out their
salvation with fear and trembling
that attitude is now a right-wing
attitude so if you have that attitude
you are somewhere on the right
um how did that happen well I think it
happened because ideas first of all
follow themselves follow themselves out
to their furthest extreme and the idea
that the government uh should is is the
solution to problems has followed itself
out to its its furthest extreme but also
power corrupts and the left has so much
power
um you know this is what killed me
during the Trump administrations they
call themselves The Resistance so I
thought so you've got you've got the
Deep State you know the Deep Cover the
permanent government you've got the uh
media you've got the entertainment and
the news media the academies you've got
now the corporations you've got big Tech
what are you resisting against I thought
oh yeah you're resisting the people
you're existing the ordinary guy so you
know the idea of the left has played
itself out as I keep telling my friends
on the right if we come back and win the
power we'll become corrupt because power
corrupts I mean that was the whole point
of the country the whole point of this
country was to create a sort of uh Rube
Goldberg machine that every time
somebody came too powerful somebody else
knocked them down you know oh you know
you've got the states we've got the
federal government you've got the courts
we you know we've got the uh the states
whatever it was there was always some
Power Center to take it away but
beginning with the turn of the century
beginning really with Woodrow Wilson
this the federal government be started
to become so powerful uh and and the Le
that is the left-wing's dream to have a
federal government that can tell
everybody what to do so they've got they
want they won and when you win you lose
you know when you when you win you your
ideas stagnate you know there's no one
there's no one they can't Crush there's
no one they can't destroy there's no
idea they can't demonize
um you know there's one
now that's not quite true but for the
last say 30 years there's been one
conservative news station Fox News and
all you heard was all fall Fox and oh my
God you know you would say to people
like I heard yesterday on Fox News oh
Fox no no don't tell me about Fox News
you think like one one new station and
that's the problem with the country is
that one group of people you know now
it's it's Tucker Carlson you know Tucker
Carlson you know has I don't always
agree with Tucker Carlson but he's like
he's like you mentioned his name and
it's like you mentioned Satan they're so
powerful they can demonize anybody they
can silence anybody they can cancel
anybody so why should they discuss
things why should they discuss anything
with anybody and so that to me is death
it's all about power it's all about
power you know and and and we have
forgotten if you go back and read The
Federalist Papers where they're arguing
for the Constitution against the people
who didn't want
um who thought the federal government
was going to get too strong they only
turned out to be right several hundred
years later
um they all they talk about is power all
those people you know this is Madison
and uh you know all these guys and all
they talk about is how do we keep people
from getting too much power
um and and we have forgotten that that's
even a a problem so when you say
when you say for instance
um you know we've got all these
shootings in this country these mass
shootings we should get rid of people's
guns
nobody even on the right people don't
think to say well isn't that giving the
federal government a monopoly on
violence and it's not giving them too
much power you know the answer is always
no guns save lives guns you know protect
us we need guns for home protection
that's not why they gave us guns they
give us guns so the states would have
the power to form militias to fight the
army of the federal government that is
why they gave us guns I tried to explain
this to a conservative British
broadcaster and he looked at me like I
was a Savage you know and I said I get
it you know I don't want people getting
shot but that's why we have guns are we
not going to at least debate the real
reason why Americans are supposed to
carry guns when when you say oh here's a
poor person I'm going to start a federal
program to save that person my question
is isn't that a Temptation you know
aren't we giving you money so that now
you can buy that guy's vote essentially
you know
I don't want people to be poor I want
you know I want charity to flow in this
country when people are rich I want the
charity to flow to those who are
disadvantaged but don't we even debate
how power collects how power follows
money are we not even going to talk
about that it's all about power when it
comes to politics that's what politics
is
and we don't even talk about it anymore
the idea that you know obviously if if a
right-winger starts to do something the
Press will gang I was always a fascist
you know he disagreed with me as a
fashion but if the left does something
no matter how much power a great example
recently they indicted Donald Trump on
an absolutely nonsense charge absolute
nonsense complete abuse of power by the
uh New York D.A all we heard from the
left was ever no one's Above the Law no
one's Above the Law I kept saying what
law was even died I don't know but all
right no one's above the law
then the Supreme Court made a decision
that Alexandria ocasio-cortez our
left-wing Firebrand uh you know
congresswoman didn't like so well we
should ignore the courts
but they have so much power that no
one's Above the Law if you're a
conservative oh you started during
covert you mentioned it earlier right we
saw in the UK everyone must stay at home
for the safety of everyone BLM happens
everyone must go out into the streets
because protesting is a health
intervention right right but yeah but if
you protest the lockdowns then you're
right-wing scum and you should have your
face that's the thing that's power and
when you have that kind of power you
don't argue with that why would you
argue and you can just silence people in
a recipe you know and then and then your
ideas die and you have no ideas and
that's that's basically where the left
is now I mean they are a rotten branch
and that's why I mean everything is
what's the word uh everything's
circumstantial so we have circumstances
here that
that may make it difficult to win power
back from them but as a but they're just
a rotten branch and eventually they're
going to just break off because they
have nothing to say except give me more
you know give me more power it's an
emergency give me power you know you
know the more I I spend time in this
country and I love America so much I
really do and I I hope that I one day
come to live here
it seems to me that America the thing
that set it apart from every other
country
is that it was forged with Rebel spirit
and I look at it now
and there doesn't seem to be a lot of
that Spirit left is that part of the
problem yeah the you know even the right
even the right has has fallen a foul
of has tripped over its own ideas you
know when when the right
Ronald Reagan gave us 25 good years
and that what he did got translated into
business is everything the market is
everything that's not what Reagan
believed but that's what the reaganites
believe and so we had this Market Market
that would talk about Ein Rand who to my
mind is just a sociopath you know like
not not to mention a terrible terrible
writer
um but that that's kind of empty too you
know like this this whole notion that
some system is going to take care of us
uh
it just doesn't work I I think we
definitely need there's a lot of things
we need and I hesitate to say to
Englishmen that one of them is uh is a
rebirth of religion but uh it's true I
mean if we don't if we don't at least
start talking as if we live we're
Spirits instead of animals
um I think that we're we're finished you
know we're finished we can't make the
arguments we need to make in a
materialist way
um
you know I forgot what was your original
question it was about the rebel Spirit
or the rebel Spirit yes well that
that is also this question well it is it
does go back to materialism because if
you're afraid to die
everything comes down to I must save my
life at all costs how can you be a rebel
why would you be a rebel against how how
powerful would you be how powerful
how much would you go against the power
to say what you have to say New York I I
lived in New York during one of the
worst times in the 70s 1970s it was you
could hardly go out without you know
dodging bullets I mean it was really
something I used to go to work at three
in the morning uh and I would run from
my apartment to stand in front of a
um a marketplace where there were
prostitutes because I figured if there
were prostitutes the mob wouldn't let
there be violence and I was the only guy
who in my Newsroom who didn't get mugged
because that's what I would do every
morning it was terrible but it was tough
I mean the New Yorkers were tough and
they were they really would not kowtow
to anybody when covid came you know my
daughter still lives in New York I'd go
and visit and everybody was like oh
you're not wearing a mask you know don't
come near me they were terrified they
were terrified so something you know
maybe it's maybe it's wealth maybe it's
too much wealth maybe it's too much
safety uh you know this is a wealthy
safe country in a lot of ways but also
this kind of idea that death is the end
you know this this this this flesh is
all you've got you've got to take care
of it you know because now we can be so
healthy for so long we mustn't sacrifice
all those wonderful years that we've got
you know I don't want to die nobody
wants to die but like that you must
believe in something bigger than
yourself we have become cowardly haven't
because you know people talk about
cancer culture and you know people
shouldn't be canceled I agree but you
know people say to us oh you're so brave
you know you stood up to the comedy
industry and started
what are you talking about what's Brave
about it I said this you know when I got
thrown out of Hollywood we had to sell
our house we were living in one of the
nicest areas in the country we had to
sell our house because my my income went
from sometimes seven figures to nothing
like that I mean just gone you know
I never lost a moment's sleepover I mean
I wasn't happy about it but I kept
saying to people you know people are in
Afghanistan they're having their legs
blown off like 18 year old kids are
being blown to Kingdom Come fighting for
something that they think has to be
fought for
I can't work in Hollywood you know oh
really am I that scared you know and and
like believe me as you say we're not
Heroes I mean those guys were Heroes you
know we're not we're but but
We're Men I mean we have to we have to
stand for something you have to be
somebody you know
um and and so yeah that that has gone
terribly terribly wrong this idea that
some
you know it's funny that like my career
has gone well and I've been really
thrilled but it wasn't until I got to
the Daily wire that I became a celebrity
that I became somebody that gets
recognized and I remember and so I was
old you know I was like and I remember
walking into a hotel and being mobbed
like a rock star because I was talking
politics on the internet you know just
like I pressed to the wall by like a
hundred kids like and I thought well if
this had happened to me when I was 20 I
would be like genuinely lost I mean I
would have genuinely become a fool you
know but now I think like
you know it comes and goes you know I
get it but this has become so important
to people that once they get their hands
on it they don't want to let go of and
they become afraid yeah the idea oh my
God I might be canceled and you see it
it's so pitiful it breaks my heart to
see people come out and say you know
something so obvious like a man can't
become a woman you know is that somebody
I can't remember who it was just said JK
Rowling is Right within minutes she
apologized oh I'm so sorry you know that
kind of Soviet uh show trial thing like
I'm so sorry I'm a sinner I'm you know
please
yeah yeah you know when someone is
really messed up because they take a
screenshot of an apology and then pin it
to their Twitter yeah you have to zoom
in
that's the moment you know oh somebody's
friends they're really [__] up yeah
they have really messed this one up I I
have reached a point where like I don't
even apologize for things that I should
apologize for you know like I mean there
are things you really should apologize
for but at this point it's just blood in
the water to these people you know I
mean yeah now you have to apologize when
you've done something wrong of course we
have to model that I think yeah more
than anything don't you think part of
the problem with the Arts is to me the
artist the true artists are the rebels
and there's no Rebellion anymore if you
if you think about the great writers
they were the rebels The Comedians were
the Rebels the actors who did we fall in
love with the Jimmy Deans the Jack
Nicholsons and Marlon brandos they just
want people accepted by Society
no that's true that's true and they
represented that that Force certainly
since since the Romantic Era that was
the idea of the artist the artist was a
special thing he was he was you know it
almost was a replacement of the priest
but you know
Rebellion yes but I don't think it's
necessarily
bit that Rebellion is the key thing I
think it's freedom freedom because even
even a conservative an artist who is
writing for the conservative cause a
trollop say you know somebody who's
actually more uh who who likes the
established things than the traditional
things he's got to be free to say that
in the exactly the way he means to say
it and so I don't require of an artist
that he Rebel because first of all
Rebellion now has become just virtue
signaling I mean people rebel like I
said they call themselves uh the uh
resistance but they're really the power
uh I don't think Rebellion is the thing
I'm looking for I'm Looking For Freedom
um you know we're talking about JK
Rowling when I read some I I have I'm
not a child so I didn't read all of the
Harry Potter books but I read a couple
of them just to sample them because my
kids were so into them I thought yeah
there's a there's a someone who is free
with her creativity she is being
generous she's just saying I'm not
saving this for the next page I'm
throwing it on this page I'm getting you
know that kind of Liberty that you see
in genuine artists and I think it's
liberty more than Rebellion I think I
think it becomes Rebellion because the
minute power sees Liberty it seeks to
crush it so it becomes Rebellion you
know so you have to stand where you're
going to stand but but you know I I
think of Shakespeare sometimes and
sometimes the the great movies that were
made during the Hayes office years and
they didn't necessarily rebel against
the power they subverted it by being
free you know they just subverted it by
saying things you know that you should
have gotten arrested for but you didn't
because they didn't say it in a
rebellious way but they were they were
free and I think that that's what
artists have to be and I I think you
know when you were talking about the
fact that we're having a kind of
conversation that people don't have
that's what it is we're free you know
and and in order to be free you have to
understand that somebody's going to want
to come and get you for it and do it
anyway you're going to lose some money
you're going to lose some friends you're
going to lose some uh you might be
thrown off Twitter you know all those
things
um you know that that is what freedom is
freedom is not being afraid of losing
those things and once you become afraid
you're not free anymore well maybe you
are afraid but you do it anyway well yes
of course that's real courage yeah yeah
I mean yeah Andrew a couple of questions
before we wrap up uh given everything
we've talked about
Dr Sebastian Gorka was sitting where
you're sitting
we left it exactly as it is just for you
um he's he's very big on Trump and
you've talked about
how it was a sad day that Trump had to
come along and you're not on the Trump
train now
yeah that that's right I said from the
very beginning I think that the two I
have to say that I think the two people
who got Trump exactly right were me and
Victor Davis handsome and I think I said
it first but Victor wrote a great book
about it so he so he wins but like but
still it was that he was a tragic figure
from the start and he was a tragic
figure because the very things that made
him great also made him wrong and also
we're going to destroy him I mean that's
what tragedy is the things that that
made him worth seeing and worth
supporting were ultimately going to
destroy him
I think he lost that second election I I
I said he was going to I knew he was
going to about two years in
because we had reached a point where it
took a loud mouth without many of the
traits that we think of as common
decency to say the simplest truth
you know I mean that was the thing that
was beautiful about Donald Trump he
would say things that could easily be
interpreted as racist he was not a
racist I don't think he I don't think he
was a racist at all but he would say
things that could easily be interpreted
as right because he didn't care if they
called them races
but he also treated people badly he
fired men who deserve would you couldn't
disagree with them you can say they're
doing a bad job but he firemen who are
deserving of respect in public or he you
know it was like he pulled the rug out
from under them he called people names
he made up names which was an adolescent
thing to do it all worked you know I I
got it I under I understood it the
minute I saw the people react to it I
didn't understand it at first but the
middle I saw the people react to it I
thought oh he's speaking for them he is
the voice of the people but at the same
time he was the voice of the people he
was also this narcissistic uh guy
without very good manners and I think
that that's what killed him I think
it'll kill him again if he runs I think
he's the only the only Republican who
could possibly lose to Joe Biden he
might not he might beat him but I think
he's the only one who could lose to him
so you a DeSantis guy yeah I I like the
Santos he hasn't been tested on the
national scene you know but I really
like his fighting attitude and as Gorka
will tell you he wouldn't exist if it
weren't for Trump everything good
Republican party has come down from
Trump he he recreated the Republican
Party the the guts they sometimes show
now which they never did before the uh
the the unwillingness to Simply drift to
the left which they've been doing for
decades uh all of that was a gift to
Trump the the big idea which somebody
told me years ago was the idea that
Republicans need to understand is you're
not running against the Democrats you're
running against the Press but the press
the media the news media in this country
is the enemy of the people just like
Trump said it was he was if there was
one thing he was a hundred percent right
about it was the news media watch I just
the other day played a montage of him
taking the Press apart I was in I
couldn't stop laughing I mean it was
just it was delightful he he was the man
of the moment he was the man we needed
um I have I have many many good things
to say about them people who say oh
you're never Trump or just lying I was
the first guy at the daily wire to come
in and say I'm voting for Trump and
Shapiro yelled at me for like hours you
know like if you've ever heard the way
Shapiro talks about yeah that scene
where the Godfather where Sonny gets
machine gunned
[Music]
um and I voted for him twice and I vote
for him again if I have to but I think
if if he had if he had an ounce of Grace
he would say I christened DeSantis the
new me and let him go if nothing else
I'm so tired of 80 year old men running
our government you know 70 and 80 year
old men it is time for this new
generation to come along and the census
is good at what he does I mean he took
that state and he turned he took he took
a purple State and he turned it into a
red state by sheer competence you know
by getting it right
Trump didn't really accomplish that much
in terms of long term because he wasn't
you know people always say well he's not
a politician being a politician is a
profession you know so he couldn't get
any laws passed everything was executive
orders was all wiped Away by Joe Biden
um so yeah I think his time came I think
he was the man of the moment uh cometh
the hour cometh the man he was a gift I
always say he was a godsend but so was
King Soul you know after a while you
know your time runs out uh he was a
godsend he was he was the man of the
moment uh and I think that moment is
passed and if the Republicans can learn
what he taught them they will become a
great party
and the final thing I want to ask you
before we do our usual uh last question
is you know I've talked about how what
we need is a post-woke world because
wokeness is crazy we all know I think
it's the every action causes an equal
and opposite reaction I see the
anti-work side which we're part of to
some extent going crazy to now
staring into the abyss thing and we need
to move beyond that do you have a vision
for how we do that I do you won't like
it though
go to church well you know I mean that
our churches your churches are empty our
churches are sort of uh collapsing uh
but we should make new ones we need to
make new ones we need to make churches
we need to gather in our homes together
as they did it first and talk about what
it means for there to be a god
um because here's the here's the thing
there actually is a god it doesn't
matter whether you believe in or not
there actually is one life even the
things you believe in only make sense if
there's a God there you know if there's
any the only leap of faith I ever took
the only leap of faith I ever took was
to say
it's it's better to give a beggar bread
than it is to torture a child to death
you can't make that case without God
that case once you believe that you
believe in God once you believe that
there is some
level above us that our actions refer to
right because what you're saying when
you're saying something is good is
you're saying there is some place where
there is good and bad and our
uh our actions speak that
it's it's not that I have a little Ghost
Inside Me that's going to float up to
heaven when I die it's that I am I I
speak an idea I am a word that speaks an
idea of me the idea of me and that idea
exists somewhere you know it exists in
the mind of God
and so
I don't think we have to go back to the
Middle Ages I don't think we can go back
to the Middle Ages and we shouldn't if
we could but I think we need to talk
about what it means if no this is not a
Multiverse where we just happen to live
in the universe that looks very much
like it was created by a gigantic
invisible Jew you know
that we there actually is something
spiritual something Supernatural
something above nature in the world and
if we don't
um if we don't say that we have no
argument this this is what I it's
hard to accept I understand I understand
why it's hard to accept but
if we don't make that argument then the
left is right why should you embrace
your gender you know I heard I was Mary
Harrington I was reading Mary's book and
uh she was talking about a man a young
man who went into puberty and said I'm
being poisoned by these chemicals these
chemicals are turning me into something
I don't want to be and I thought well
that's a rational statement if there's
no God
you don't want to be this and these
chemicals are in fact turning you into
something but if that's something that
you are refers to something above
yourself which I'm that's what I believe
I believe we are a language material is
a language
then there's a reason to sort of say
well what am I going to do with this
manhood that's been given to me this you
know what is this manhood does is it a
what if it's a gift what if it has
obligations what if I have an obligation
uh to open the door for my wife even
though she's perfectly capable of
opening the door for herself what if I
have an obligation to throw myself in
front of her if there's danger you know
what does it mean to be a man what does
it mean to be a woman uh
what are the sacrifices I'm willing to
make to be that person
you cannot make that argument
um without some sense of the spiritual
and to be honest even though I'm a
devout Christian and I believe that that
is the ex the great expression of truth
because it's so human
um you know I just think you have to
start from somewhere you know that
they're that they're we're not we're not
just uh what's what's the word they you
know we're not Meat Puppets you know
we're not uh we're something else we are
we speak a word so that that is the
beginning of the anti-woke thing that
you know C.S Lewis great Christian uh
apologist said you can't really he was
talking about a poem he was talking
about Paradise Lost he said you can't
really judge a thing until you know what
it's for you know you can't really judge
a corkscrew until you know what it's
supposed to do and so you can't really
judge people in society until you have
some you can State what it's supposed to
be and for too long the right has been
saying well we you're happier if you can
make money you know the answer then
America gives you the right to make
money and then you can make more money
and if you and if you can even make more
money you think like eventually people
turn around and say you know
that's not doing it for me you know that
does it for some people some people want
to be billionaires you know never
occurred to me if I want to be a
billionaire I certainly wouldn't have
gone into the writing profession you
know there's something that we're here
for and I do think it involves love and
relationship and love of something
Beyond ourselves that this world only
expresses
and when you begin with that you get
very quickly to ideas like freedom uh to
ideas like relationship
marriage uh respect you know again we
don't have to go back to the Middle Ages
to realize that those are things that
that matter to us and that you can build
a society on you can't build a society
on like oh you know you're a black guy
so you committed a crime but you're not
a criminal because black people were
oppressed that's like you know then you
get what we have in Chicago now which is
being Torn to Pieces as we sit here
talking the poor people pouring into the
streets tearing into pieces
um you cannot build a society like that
woke is right if there's no God woke is
some some bits of work makes sense if
there's no God
um and it better be a god
Bingo if there's not we're in big
trouble yeah
Andrew what a pleasure it's been uh
thank you so much for coming on the show
if people want to find your books if
they want to follow you online if they
want to watch you on the wire how do
they do that well you can start by going
to andrewclaven.com yes I always say
there's no ease in Cleveland it's
k-l-a-v-a-n
um but Andrew cleveland.com will send
you all my other places and Andrew Clay
at Andrew claven as my Twitter feed and
and the daily wire I've got my podcast
is now on every Friday
um and uh it's different no one else no
one else does what I do so it's
something it's worth it's worth tuning
in absolutely fantastic it's great to
talk to you well thank you it's been an
absolute pleasure and of course we're
not going to let you go without some
questions for uh paid supporters or
locals that only they'll get to see but
before that the last question we always
ask and you may have done this already
but what is the one thing we're not
talking about as a society yeah that was
my last answer I mean I think this
started in in the 1500s this decline you
know the long withdrawing Roar of the
tide of faith I think we have now
reached the bottom of that Niche said
you know this is a catastrophe that God
is dead and the moral Network on which
Europe is based has is gone uh and this
and he said this is going to be a
catastrophe it certainly has been you
know
um and so that that's the thing we're
not talking about because we're we've
got this idea that you can't make an
argument from God because not everybody
accepts that premise
but when you make the argument that
there's no God that's a premise I don't
accept so I think that we should be
Fearless in saying in asking the
question asking the questions of the
left you know I think that was what was
so great about Matt Walsh's documentary
what is a woman he asked the question
yeah that's a spiritual question you
know that's not a physical question
that's a spirit you know because when
you say what is a woman it's not really
the x's and the Y's and the this and
that that a woman is we know what a
woman is the minute we see it you know
and I think we have to ask those
questions what do you think you're here
for what is what is your purpose you
know
you tell me
um because I'll build that Society
uh and I think once you do that you get
very quickly to something that looks
kind of like the Constitution uh you
know power being kept at Bay so the
individual can thrive
there we go Andrew Cleveland it was
absolute pleasure talking to you thank
you so much for coming on the show join
us on locals where we're going to ask
Andrew some of your bonus questions take
care and we'll see you soon take care
and see you soon guys
envisage a politically neutral
filmmaking industry and what steps
events would it take to achieve that
outcome
foreign
[Music]